Smart. Less. Media. Hey guys, so Smart Less Media has a new show coming out. It's called Staying Alive. It's awesome. It's hosted by Adam Pally and John Grabus. And, sorry, Gay Bris. Gay Bris. I changed the R and the A. I don't know. No, no, no.
Please, I do it. It's fine. Gay Bris. Also, there is something garbous and gar know if it's something you do all the time. Please, I do it. It's fine. Also, there is something garbous and garbled. There's something garbage and looking at John. It's like there's something that you wanna just say. There's a lot of work going on there. Mons pubis.
By the way, we can talk about that in a whole episode. So, it premieres Thursday, April 24th, which is just around the corner. And new episodes released every Thursday. You guys, I'm so happy you guys are doing this. It's very exciting. Please tell, because I fucking do a horrible job, please tell us what it's about.
Look, this is so exciting. You are one of our pod fathers. I guess in our contract, you requested we call you that. So we're so excited to be part of this. I'm acting like it's not in the contract. All right, sorry, we're supposed to keep that up too. Now I can call you daddy in another frame of reference. Now I can call you daddy in front of other people.
If I had a dollar, okay, yeah, tell us. So basically John and I have been best friends and comedy partners for a long, long time and we hosted a travel show called 101 Places to Party Before You Die, which is on Max. And we like to indulge and we kind of live by this lifestyle of like when in Rome and oftentimes that Rome is Las Vegas.
So it's like, we tend to get down and we find ourselves kind of growing up a little bit and thinking, well, we're in our early 40s now and like you do have to counteract. Speak for yourself, John, early 40s. Are you mid 40s? Are you calling yourself mid 40s now and like you do have to counteract speaking for yourself John early 40s Are you mid 40s? That's that's how the term mid started Emphasis on the mid over here tech availed to play Sam Fried
I'm on ice. I'm on ice. I'm on ice for Sam Freed. Put a pin in me. I'm trying to play Jack Black's before pictures. So I'm on ice. Ah! But so we took an interest, we both have an interest in staying alive as long as we can. It's so good. You know, it's such a thing that all of a sudden
you try to, you find yourself talking about, right? Everybody. Right, in your 20s and 30s, you just party, you eat whatever you want, you drink whatever you want, you go anywhere, you know, right, in your thirties, in your twenties and thirties, it's just part of you eat whatever you want, you drink whatever you want, you do go anywhere, you do anybody you want. Like anything, anything that brings like pleasure or whatever.
And then all of a sudden you find yourself. With lower back pain. Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly. You're like, you talk to your, hey man, what's going on with it? Do you have this problem too? Like, does it hurt when you pee? Or like whatever it is, right?
And you start talking about it. I noticed that too, it's like. It. Part of the impetus to the show was we wanted to talk to health and wellness professionals to learn more and bring that information to other people but also once you're a certain age all your conversations with even comics if you're not shit talking another comic the thing you're talking about is like yeah have you started taking fish oil yet are you doing vitamin C tablets? Or whatever? It's like, what are you streaming and what's wrong with you physically?
Yes, exactly. That's a great one. What are you watching and what's wrong with you? How are your streams, your piss and your movies? Yeah. Right, exactly. Weak, all of them weak. Dribbly.
Dribbly. So can you tell us like one of the things that was the most, I know you probably get asked this a lot, but one of the most eye-opening things are the things that you implement now more than ever. Well, I mean, it runs the gamut from like, we had an immunologist on from the NIH who told us one of the simple things you can do is add,
I'm gonna say it wrong, but cruciferous. You got it. Cruciferous vegetables into your diet. And now we use that word just to kind of feed big dog you a little bit, Sean, but that means broccoli and cauliflower. We're so happy to have learned it that we bring it up in every conversation. So basically she was like, those are the vegetables
that are really worth your- What do you mean, like if you just eat those, you're good? They're nutrient dense. They're nutrient dense and they're worth it to add to your diet. If you're not eating them, get them in. So a general physician would say, okay, if you're ordering Chinese food,
chicken and broccoli is not a bad order because you're getting broccoli. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. You know. Okay, very good. It's simple things on that level. But then we also had a friend on, Elna, who told us that salvia can transport you to the quantum realm and you can experience
true formlessness. Now I don't know if I'm gonna bring that into my routine, my health routine, adding some rips of salvia, but this is the kind of information you can get at Staying Alive. I love that, it's everything I'm for, because I need this. The other day, literally just a week ago,
Will Arnett said to me, I said, he goes, what'd you do yesterday? And I was like I have this lunch with an agent of mine and then and he goes lunch and I go yeah I like to keep my dinners free and he goes from what vegetables I never eat No, it's crazy that I'm in my but I super late 20s and I'm being told eat more vegetables and I'm taking that as like Holy shit, I haven't really considered that Yeah, I mean I had it in juice like that's just like the way that I'm getting it
in a juice form Stuff a cauliflower into my blunt There's already one there remote control out of there first. My vibrating, my vibrating cauliflower. His television remote. That only Adam has the remote to. All right, we're gonna listen to the trailer really quick, here we go. Listen up podcast fans, Joe Rogan, Theo Vaughn, Tim Dillon won't be on our show at all.
They've said no. They've said no. Because of our beliefs. That's Adam Pally. That's John Gabris. They said no. They said no. Because of our beliefs. Ha ha ha ha. Ha ha ha ha. That's Adam Pally. That's John Gabras. And we are the co-hosts of Smartless Media's new podcast called Staying Alive.
That's right, Staying Alive, our new health and wellness podcast that is neither for the healthy or well. Well, it's maybe for health by health. Ha ha ha ha. We'll have guests like our friend actor Jerry O'Connell. Pally, you are looking good. Well, it's maybe for health by health We'll have guests like our friend actor Jerry O'Connell. Pally you are looking good. Thank you I've seen you not looking good. Yeah, and you're looking good. Thank you. You're not the first guest to say I've seen you look worse Comedian Paul Scheer. I love the cold plunge. I found a lot of success. Do you have one in your house? I do I also flooded my house with it, but that's why it's outside. It's outside.
Ketamine therapist Dr. Steven Radowitz. It's called spiritual herd immunity. Now when you're in this place, I start to see through those things. I believe in spiritual herd immunity because I'm a spiritual anti-vaxxer. Yeah. So I think that that's kind of the only way.
Eggo Wodum talking to us about how she hates breakfast. Here's my thing is I don't have an appetite in the morning because I'm eating up until the minute I close my eyes. And I'm serious. Cardiologist Dr. Amar Sheer. Stress actually it affects the blood pressure so as much as you can kind of reduce your stress. And it's chill to do coke right?
Definitely don't do coke. Okay, alright, not chill to do coke. right? Definitely don't do coke. Okay, alright, not chill to do coke. Jillian Bell. I think it's natural also for our age too, like... Jillian's 25, and you and I... I'm a hard 25. You're a hard 25, yeah, you've lived a life. And I'm a road hard 34.
And I'm not that hard, and 43. And so many more, so many more. You know, Adam and I, we may not be wellness experts, but I can tell you this. We are curious freaks who love to talk about this shit. And we've done enough harm to our bodies to know that now's the time to maybe make a change. Yeah, we can't say we can make a U-turn in our lives,
but at least we could pump the brakes a little. And maybe make a left. Hey, two wrongs don't make a left. Yeah. Hey, two wrongs don't make a left. Right. Correct. Staying Alive premieres April 24th anywhere you get your podcasts. Get them a week early and ad free
with SiriusXM Podcast Plus on Apple Podcasts. Visit SiriusXM Podcast Plus to start your free trial today. Check out the video version of the show on YouTube on the Smartless Media channel. Yeah, and why don't you do us a favor in the meantime? You guys you're awesome, I can't wait for everybody to hear this Adam Pally John gabris Staying alive again premieres Thursday April 24th. Here's a fucking hilarious. Great idea for a show. I will totally be listening. Thank you for doing it.
Thank you, Shawnee. Thank you for not only having us here, but green lighting us in general. Thank you for the green light. Guys, it was exhausting green lighting you. I know, you really, you carried us over that finish line. We need someone to push the ball uphill like you, Shawnee. And you are gonna delete all the photos you said, right?
That's it, done, done and done. Okay, thank you. We're like Sean Spacey over there. That's fucking hilarious. Smart. Blast. Media. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.